un punto que probablemente debería de
dejar claro es que esta idea de obtener
un 2% en honorarios de dirección y
después participar en el 20 por ciento
de las ganancias esto esto en realidad
no es una estrategia exclusiva los
fondos de cobertura también lo puedes
encontrar en estructuras de compensación
que normalmente encuentran en fondos de
capitales de riesgo o en capital privado
y para ser claros el capital de riesgo
es una forma de capital privado pero
normalmente cuando se refiere a capital
privado no se refieren a qué riesgo en
particular en todas estas situaciones
los clientes obtienen un 2% alrededor de
eso por por la administración de los
fondos y un 20 por ciento de las
ganancias la diferencia realmente está
en términos de cómo está estructurado y
un fondo de capital privado o de capital
de riesgo aún tendrán una sociedad
limitada ok en para el fondo y entonces
tendrán que conseguir una compañía que
administre obtenga los honorarios de
administración y también tenga ganancias
la única diferencia es que debido a que
un fondo de cobertura en la mayoría de
los casos va a invertir en seguridades
públicas puede obtener el dinero directo
del inicio y poner ese dinero en
circulación
tener tendencia de invertir en activos
con liquidez que ellos puedan salir y
adquiridos entonces un fondo de
cobertura probablemente tomará tanto
dinero como requiere para invertir desde
el inicio una firma de capitales de
riesgo o una firma de capitales privados
lo que harán es decir mira voy a
recaudar recaudar un fondo de 100
millones de dólares pero no voy a ser
capaz de marchar mañana e invertir 100
millones de dólares en este caso ellos
tendrán que observar a empresarios y
hacer sus diligencias de vidas lo mismo
para una firma de capitales privados
ellos tendrán que buscar compañías que
deseen comprar verdad estamos hablando
de compañías con mayor madurez que estas
compañías piensen que pueden comprar y
cambiarlas tal vez algunas compañías
maduras que requieran dinero para crecer
rápidamente el capital de riesgo tiende
a invertir en algunos individuos y sus
planes de negocios o tal vez en
compañías más pequeñas y arriesgadas
pero ninguna de estas en ninguna de
estas situaciones las hallarán mañana
entonces lo que hacen es decir con sus
inversionistas y harán que ellos se
comprometan a cierta cantidad de dinero
digamos 100 millones de dólares y
obtendrán el honorario de dirección
obtendrán este honor
en lo que estos inversionistas
comprometan pero no tomarán el dinero en
ese momento ahí mismo tomarán el dinero
como lo requiera verdad van a decir
acabo de hallar una inversión buena de 5
millones y ahora necesito este
porcentaje de lo que has comprometido
para que yo pueda invertir esto esto no
ocurre en el fondo de cobertura no es el
caso todo es de entrada pero realmente
es el mismo esquema de compensación y es
por eso que si deseas ir a una buena
escuela de negocios encontrarás que
estos son el tipo de carreras por lo
menos es es la gente que que está
interesada en pues bueno no desee
otorgarles cualquier clase de
características existen muchos motivos
por los cuales hay gente que desee
entrar en estas pero en definitiva estas
son carreras muy perseguidas en las
escuelas de negocios